How are we doing guys we're all about to die you
said this would be a relaxing holiday i said it
was going to be like a relaxing holiday times like
this we need to come together quite a reunion huh
what a classic thor adventure flick
okay we should go thor love and thunder tickets
on sale monday
Welcome back everyone marvel just
released a brand new thor love and thunder trailer
video there's a bunch of new scenes a bunch of new
easter eggs so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're also doing a special
giveaway during this video too thanks to my
friends at bespoke post who has to sponsor this
giveaway with some of their subscription boxes
so i'll be giving each of these different
kits away all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and post all your predictions in
the comments below bespoke post is a monthly
membership club that sends you really cool boxes
of these top shelf goods it's free to join and you
can skip a month or cancel any time each box has
around 70 dollars worth of goods inside but cost
you just a fraction of the value you'll get the
box assigned to you before it's shipped you'll
get a preview of what comes inside to decide
if you like it one or two you can swap it for
a different box or three you can actually skip the
month entirely for no charge you only pay for what
you want the boxes that they send you are a theme
based on your interest for this giveaway they
sent me the roast kit the hibernation kit in the
weekender kit the big one here the weekender kit
comes with this really cool heirloom level bag
this is actually pretty sweet the roast kit is
coffee roast themed it comes with this cool coffee
maker a burr grinder and a really cool packet of
coffee you seriously have no idea how much coffee
it takes to make all these videos every day
they have many many different kinds of boxes that
you can select from for your subscription to get
20 off your first box click on the link in the
description i'll put it up on screen here or you
can enter the code at checkout at bespokepost.com
emergency20. what i'll do is i'll name the three
different giveaway winners from this in one of my
next couple of videos so be sure to enable alerts
for that so you don't miss it but in the new
trailer we get way more guardians of the galaxy
footage explaining a little bit about what's going
on with them early in the movie and what thor has
been doing this whole time in addition to losing
all that weight he walks up to the battle and i
think we've decided this planet is a centaurian
planet the blue race that yondu comes from
his fin that he wore wasn't a genetic thing
that was a mechanical custom weapon that he wore
but thor walks up to the battle wearing that same
cloth that draped over him that we saw when he was
sitting under the tree that korg is also near
when he's narrating thor's life story the story
of the space viking in the background when he's at
that tree you can actually see there are two other
figures walking up to try and get him presumably
it's to the other guardians of the galaxy asking
him to come help everyone enjoying the battle like
please pull your weight we're in the middle of
a big problem here just more of him being really
lazy which is classic bro thor like you saw during
avengers end game out of the way lebowski he walks
up to the guardians of the galaxy all casual like
like he's been meditating for a long time just
asking them how everything's going but they're
in the middle of fighting for their lives in this
giant pitch battle with a group of aliens even
drax is yelling about how they're all going to die
rocket yells at him saying that this was supposed
to be a relaxing vacation as if somehow disaster
follows thor like white on rice you see star-lord
and the others get kind of sick of him he unfurls
that cloak to reveal his thor asgardian-themed
ravager's uniform and they're just calling him
ravager store in all the toys that they're selling
for this it's made to look like eric masterson's
thunderstrike thor costume from the 80s but he's
got the gold boots from the classic jack kirby
thor costume which he's actually wearing when
you see the young thor in the montage he's got
the world tree looking version of the t-shirt
from big trouble little china like it's a tank
top t-shirt it's designed to look like kurt
russell's big trouble little china t-shirt but it
is the world tree design you remember that kurt
russell is also known as ego the living planet
in the mcu peter quill's father his belt buckle
looks like it's also a world tree themed design
and his jacket is a sleeveless ravager's jacket
and even though we don't see it till later in the
trailer he's got that giant back tattoo that tells
some of his story he's probably got tattoos on
other places of his body but it seems like the
back tattoo is the big thing it's a little too
blurry to see all the different things that he
has written all over the place here but you do see
loki's horns with rip loki on it you just wonder
what the variant of loki during the loki series
would think of something like that remember his
loki died during avengers infinity war the main
version of loki now from the loki series is a
variant splitting off from the original avengers
movie so he didn't experience ragnarok or any of
that stuff so there's a lot of memories that he's
missing with thor he gets a couple of big costume
changes during the movie but all the guardians of
the galaxy have also gotten costume upgrades too
you can actually see peter quill is now wearing
yondu's jacket and there are some added details
that look like the designs on the metal pieces
are inspired by ego the living planet's costume
like the same celestial designs the ego had on
his jacket i think that's just meant to be him
coming to terms with his father and everything
that happened during guardians 2. in the way
they explained thor at the beginning of the movie
like very beginning when all this funny stuff is
happening is that he has accepted that he is a
real god like he's come to terms with his power
but he's confused about what he's supposed to be
doing with it like what do i do if i have so much
power because at least he thinks that new asgard
is running itself like valkyrie is taking care
of everything for him but this gets into gorr's
whole thing also the funny workout montage with
him during the beginning of the movie losing all
that weight it looks like he's slowly worn out his
welcome with the guardians of the galaxy he's not
pulling his weight just being lazy but it's all
about thor finding his true purpose in a cosmic
sense like becoming a more cosmic version of the
character the reason all these funny thor scenes
of him being super lazy just being a drag on the
guardians of the galaxy is because gorr wants to
kill all the gods because he thinks that they're
lazy and they don't care about their subjects and
i think around the time the thor starts to realize
that like oh yeah you're kind of trying to get rid
of me that's when valkyrie shows up to bring him
back to new asgard and gorr winds up attacking the
scene of valkyrie licking her sword is happening
during the battle in zeus's main chamber of the
gods here during their meeting when thor gets
captured and flicked too hard quote-unquote
going full monty in a marvel movie and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it they had that funny
moment in the other trailer where valkyrie jane
foster and korg are all kind of waiting just a
beat just to joke about it but later you do see
thor break free whipping his chains around his
weapons and they're kind of using it as a wonder
woman greek gods reference too because these
are literally the mcu version of the greek gods
wonder woman's mythology flows from the greek
gods him whipping the chains around with his
cosmic god energy just meant to look kind
of like the lasso of truth it seems like
jane foster the rest of them come to help
him in the fight and valkyrie then winds up
cutting the hell out of zeus's guards because
she and the weapon are both dripping in gold
which is what it seems like all of his
guards are made of like there might be
people underneath that armor but at least
their armor is gold they might bleed gold too
then there's a completely different scene of
her tapping her sword on jane foster's mule
near hammer like a makeshift fist bump like the
bros now in the movie tessa thompson said that
valkyrie's kind of grown tired of being king
like she's getting bored with the day-to-day
of everything like it's not as fun as she thought
that would be she really misses her sisters the
other valkyrie that died when they were fighting
hella a long long time ago then along comes jane
foster thor so in the movie she actually starts
to feel like jane foster's thor is a new sister
of hers if you haven't read the mighty thor arc
what winds up happening to jane foster's thor
character is that eventually she becomes one of
the valkyries so that could potentially happen
in the mcu they have the funny scene of thor
talking about how they need to come together it's
probably him just trying to convince valkyrie
and jane foster to come with him to find gorr
but this is happening inside the main hall at
new asgard where valkyrie acts like king doing
her day-to-day stuff the joke being that he's kind
of waiting in line to talk to her just waiting his
turn like everyone else in this room but because
he's got that brand new battle looking armor the
blue gold armor upgrade this would be after gorr
attacks new asgard i just posted a video for miss
marvel episode 1 they had an avengers convention
in universe like the very first one as if it's
going to be a big thing now there was a thor love
and thunder easter egg during that convention so
there's a person dressed in wakandan garb handing
out travel brochures for wakanda but he's also got
travel brochures for new asgard like there's a
big banner here that reads new asgard tourism
we've seen in the trailer that new asgard has
embraced tourism just trying to earn more money
there's a brand new scene of gorr using the power
of the necro sword while saying the universe would
be better without god so he's going to kill them
all they changed his character a little bit from
the comics for the movie he was still wronged
by the gods in the movie but i think they're
going to alter just a little bit in the comics
his family died and he learned that the gods
of his people which are completely different
gods that we haven't seen before in the mcu
basically just let it happen it was meant to be
this senseless death like wait you could have done
something and you didn't because you're too lazy
he found the necro sword then used it to kill his
people's gods and then went on his quest to kill
all the gods of the universe i did a moon knight
deleted scene video there was going to be a bunch
of scenes referencing gorr the god butcher because
two of the members of their pantheon the enemy
of the egyptian gods were missing it was going
to be because gorr had killed them but like for
instance konchu the rest of his pantheon would be
on gorr's list he would be going after
them but during the trailer footage you
see gorr go from just like this regular looking
alien to this emperor palpatine looking figure
like he slowly goes emperor palpatine with his
body kind of wasting away throughout the movie
that's probably a side effect of the power of
the necro sword the other brand new thing that
they've revealed are flashback scenes they're
gonna have in the movie of thor and jane foster
and what happened to them after the events of thor
of the dark world when he came back to be with her
on earth you see scenes of them on the street you
see thor looking at rings as if he's getting ready
to propose to her and this will explain why they
eventually broke up which they joked about during
the events of thor ragnarok like it had already
happened when that movie took place but natalie
portman also confirmed a big comic book theory
that a lot of people have when the first trailer
dropped she said that she starts the movie having
this huge secret that she doesn't tell thor right
away that she's basically dying of breast cancer
which is a big thing in the comics in that every
time she wields mjolnir it gets worse like she
dies a little bit quicker the reason why mjolnir
causes her to die faster when she's wielding it
is because its power basically just burns away
all the chemo in her body so the more she does is
mighty thor the faster she dies but if you spotted
any big easter eggs in the new footage that i
didn't talk about in the video just write them
below in the comments in my miss marvel videos
we'll post every week my miss marvel episode
1 link is down in the description below everyone
click here for that brand new marvel thunderbolts
movie announcement really big deal and click
here for my brand new black adam trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!